he's playing for manchester united yeah
okay why does this why do people care
uh maybe some people might care because
if he wins a uh
a champion
if he wins a championship with
manchester united then i think that puts
him ahead of messi
it's a higher level league
than the french league
i guess the top tier leagues are
the champ what is it called the uh pl
no no this uh la liga spain
yep syria and italy syria and italy and
then
english premier league yeah yeah ep and
league one is up there as far as like
psg and [ __ ] but it's not it's liga it
goes bundesliga then the french league
because how many teams are there even in
the french league like there's like one
i mean there's a legacy team that always
wins yeah exactly so it's just like you
you go and play for like the brooklyn
nets you're basically going to join
kevin durant and all these people and
the nets for the bet and and imagine
there was no other teams in the league
that you even play against so like the
messy thing isn't a really big challenge
but
manchester united is not a team that's
been killing it right they've been doing
like okay yeah they're like middle of
the field
so if you take them and you win the
championship with them
um you might have to say that ronaldo's
the best brother how good is he still
he's a legend he's made it i mean how
good is he at
for his age he's like mid-30s and he's
still like not first day he's just like
against the players relative to other
players where is he is he ron in the nba
lebron i'd say oh wow yeah i know he's
still nice so he's still top five still
goal scorer like i think he led juventus
and goals last year like
he any team he goes to he's just he's an
animal so did he leave like the spanish
team because
messi left a spanish he was playing for
an italian team yeah oh okay
so it's just the craziest transfer
window also too like this transfer
window like that you have messi moving
and bopping might be moving
yeah that's still a transformer he's
gonna leave bomb
no he scored two goals in the messages
and then [ __ ] blew
league you got some it
games
sometimes you forget i used to be bored
like you know people have bad games
[Laughter]
no but like so he might be going to real
madrid which would be just like a crazy
transfer winner you have three of the
best players that are playing like three
of the top ten that are all switching
teams going to different leagues all in
the same window right before the
champions league to like shake up hey
soccer fans welcome to american football
this happens every [ __ ] year get used
to it the nba dog nba more not even
close american football is much more
talent moving around
yeah no it's definitely nba no you just
put a franchise tag on a guy in the nfl
and he didn't really go anywhere like a
big quarterback never really leaves
really like a couple of times
in the past five six years i feel like
every year there's a big [ __ ] trade
in football like a big movement of
players every year like kevin durant
going james harden going to the nets
that was in two years kyrie irving that
was three players in two years to one
team this is like if dak prescott tom
brady and patrick mahomes all switch
teams yeah all the same like window and
then to different leagues on top of that
right before champions league just wow
it's just interesting to see it
interesting to see the shake up but are
the teams that they went to in the
championship yeah they're in the
champions league it's like okay unheard
of never happened it would be like if uh
back in the day lebron james and dwyane
wade and chris bosh all left their teams
and one played on the same team yeah
but champions league
is different
can you eat that later yeah
sorry lauren sounds so jet lagged
you're gonna [ __ ] the couch
champions league explain champions
league mark i mean it's just basically
cross competition with all the leagues
so all the biggest leagues all right
it's basically the best teams of all the
other leagues playing one the world cup
of the club teams okay yeah all right
basically so it's like yes paris yes
paris psg paris saint-germain or
whatever the team that messi's playing
on yeah yes they're gonna play
in the champions league but the rest of
the teams they're playing regularly
aren't as good as the teams that the
team you know uh real madrid would be
playing or manchester united or maybe
even juventus right i mean how many
syria odd teams are like legit legit
three yeah three four three four so it's
just i guess that's what makes a a
league itself yeah you know really good
and psg didn't even win last year that
was leel so yeah all respect to and then
the other thing that's interesting is
that he's going back to man you which is
the team that like he sort of made his
bones at and started it there was five
star there i didn't want to sound like a
[ __ ] but yeah yeah
he started there he started in portugal
but yeah i mean he started with uh
lisbon fc but then like was a star and
became a star with alex ferguson
emmanuel and then there were traders his
[ __ ] jerseys son yeah and then he
went back like it's some and did you
hear that
there was rumors he was going to go to
manchester city the man city thing
apparently is the whole thing that
provoked them to put in the offer but
apparently man you didn't even really
have major intentions to try to scoop
them up yeah like as far as like because
they actually i checked the the numbers
they finished sixth in 2019 but in 2020
they were like top of the table so
they've been like top five pretty much
for the last like few years so they've
been good but so they didn't really need
a ronaldo as far as like their budgets
and salaries and their current roster
okay but they were like we're going to
make a push for him because we can't
stand to potentially see him with our
rival
but it's kind of interesting because
like when when i was first playing fifa
when i was younger the soccer game
that's the only way i know anything
about soccer man city was not a nice
team it was manchester united that was
the [ __ ] thing that's that's the
other one was that bald [ __ ] who
was kind of nice white boy from menu
yeah back in the day
i don't remember and then he came over
and played in the mls for a little bit
and then he got his hair plugs and now
he's got some hair we're this white
british guy
played for man you
i'm looking it up hmm
nice
striker
i remember that black french dude that
came to play for la uh and then beckham
wait uh honoree yeah terry henry didn't
he play he was like he was barcelona new
york uh yeah he was arsenal
yeah but so so manchester united was
that team i think there was a guy played
for me i'm almost positive what the [ __ ]
is that guy's name white boy he got hair
plugs there's like a video of him
getting knocked out too like fighting
with like a friend really he got like
hair plugs
definite hair plugs he was like a super
salon
i don't know british guy wayne rooney
wayne rooney he wasn't bald he wasn't
bald yeah he had crazy receding hairline
he wasn't bald that's balls huh what are
we talking about over here yeah wayne
rooney you all know nothing about soccer
there's a couple of us bald in this room
if you consider that
okay so
but um so yeah so like manchester united
was nice man city comes out yeah they
all of a sudden become nice
united nothing [ __ ] man city got all
the sandpaper take all the what sand
paper that's what they call the saudi
money yeah it's oil money for us
i don't know just sounds [ __ ] up
but manchester united was born oh by a
russian oligarch yeah yeah yeah yeah so
so yeah they both got their billionaires
they're just different places yeah but
man city starts balling out right so
man city the rumors are that ronaldo is
going to go to man city and like people
that are manchester united fans start
going [ __ ] ronaldo he's over the hill
[ __ ] him there's all these like memes
and [ __ ] they're going crazy and then it
comes out that manchester united
actually signs them all the exact same
people like
he's here he's got three years left
don't worry we love him
it's funny to see like the loyalty to
club that exists within football yeah
like i feel like now in american sports
like we're loyal to players a lot more
like [ __ ]
especially nba and probably because it's
so transient yeah but like but with
soccer like i was in barcelona
[ __ ] were fans of barcelona
didn't even know the players on the team
right yeah yeah like if you ask them you
know name eight players on the team they
could not name a player but they were
die hard bleed what is it the blue red
and yellow whatever the [ __ ] it is bro
people have died literally died in like
fights for teams that have never won a
league oh yeah
like people are fighting for their life
for a team that's trash yeah you all die
for this [ __ ]
all right but hooligan culture
who's jaden sancho my brother-in-law
says he's a young kid who's nice on
manchester u i don't know oh you know
okay
but they said like he has so manchester
you apparently they've been getting a
lot of young talent and so he's gonna i
guess be the elder smith to come in and
like help him out and [ __ ] like that
he ain't going to be the help him out
oh he's going to be dumb
yeah i think he's still like he's the
man
and sometimes it's hard to you know to
play with the man
right like that's something you got to
be careful that's a risk like i guess
you hope that playing with a guy like
ronaldo you see his work ethic you see
not only his talent but his dedication
and that rubs off on the younger players
yeah he's one of those guys that's like
i'm sleeping eight hours i'm working out
twice a day i only drink water like that
was a whole coca-cola thing he was like
[ __ ] coke we don't drink coke water only
like he's like treating his body like
lebron [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah okay and that should be
looking like a tummy tuck
he's a baby
so so that's the thing like i guess you
hope some of that rubs off you just got
to hope that he's not like a jordan type
where he's breaking these little
[ __ ] because they're not
getting them the ball in the positions
that he wants it
that's the that's the risk is that you
have this young kid who's been watching
ronaldo play his entire life and his
dream is to play just like ronaldo and
now they're playing the same team and
now he's shook he's frozen
because not every one of these young
bucks is going to be like kyrie where
they want to go right at him there's
going to be some of these young bucks
that are like i can't believe i'm
playing with ronaldo yeah because he's
jordan right yeah like they're playing
with [ __ ] jordan yeah there's people
that are like i started playing just
because of you yeah we're on the same
team yeah wow and they would never think
that they would be able to they're like
he's not coming back to manchester
united yeah yeah there's no way i'm
shocked he's doing it like not even
because he could come play in the u.s
and get a piece of a team and whatever
but because you've been to lunch weather
yeah literally the weather how did i
know this i
thought about this i was like why would
you do this
you're in the twilight of your career
you could be in italy you could be in
spain you could come play in los angeles
where they take so many naps there and
[ __ ] like that why would you leave a
place you probably got more chairs in
space english women have you never seen
a girl in england bro what are you doing
like
manchester united manchester just feels
colder it's more north yeah yeah
playing we're yeah like what are you
doing why nothing like new york nothing
like that so i don't care yeah
new york outside of london england is
[ __ ] rednecks dog manchester i never
been but i went to [ __ ] birmingham
and it was like oh yeah some yokels out
here yo nah but they still got some hood
spots
yes yeah they got hot spots too [ __ ]
yoko's there too
i smell your falls in this [ __ ] i don't
know what's a yoko it's a it's a [ __ ]
country ass dude to see you a yokel bro
[ __ ] country
[Music]
yeah i never heard it right you were
just talking about going to london
london is i said outside of london
i was like that'd be a good business
move but i don't know if it's the move
that we're gonna pick up for you
i don't know man he got all the money in
the world what the [ __ ] you want to just
be in the in the clouds bro like
nah dude
he wants to be the best he wants to be
great say what he wants to be great
he wants to win the relatives athletes
we would know he seems like kobe
maybe yeah like super focused this
dedicated i'm not [ __ ] playing in l.a
kobe demanded a trade he's like i'm not
going to be in cleveland
kobe what a charlotte
right he's like i'm not doing this [ __ ]
get me to los angeles yeah
yeah
no
that's a good point i'm not doing it
right so if i'm him i'm not doing it if
he wins with this team he's like
legit the best like is it on some brady
[ __ ] if he takes another team to it he's
the goat i mean it's always up for
debate like we'll see what messi does
with psg i mean they're also the most
stacked team ever
like psg yeah psg is still stacked so
it's like if messi wins
they got neymar don't help them
they got rippery
is that right
they got the scarface they got the
[ __ ] bond villains yeah you
really did play fifa i respect that
that's the old school
they got the [ __ ] that plays
defense for real madrid it's so funny
this is only serious
they got um alex ferguson
they got alex ferguson that [ __ ]
knife with it yeah they got pele they
got they got um yeah [ __ ] kyrie
alexander
just fills up the rest of the roster
is that your favorite player my favorite
player of all time is freddie
yes who wants five foot four inch 37
year old freddy adu 37 year old high
school senior friend
so this is american soccer legend you
don't remember freddie
i met him at a soccer camp bro yeah did
you ball on his ass he was supposed to
be my age
old you had a yeah yeah dude did you
ball in his ass or what no he was the
coach of the camp oh he was coaching
yeah he was ready to do soccer camp oh
he's one of those that's why i became a
legend damn that's why you ain't make it
dawg you're the wrong side
his advice was like yo born in 1980 and
i was like god
did that
be a decade older than all the high
school kids are playing yeah
there's actually good advice if you
could do it but
most people don't want it that bad ricky
but yeah i think that um
i think alexi lawless is going to have
an amazing season bro
do you know who alexi lawless is dude
you you don't know who that is no legend
dog
you don't know anything you're going to
really struggle in europe honestly yeah
yeah you don't know what lexie loves
alexis and his all sport commercials
[ __ ] powered that that thirst
clincher back in the day you try to
advertise you don't know me and him
you're [ __ ] dude you don't know mia
hammond that sounds familiar yeah
she had a little ass on her right no she
had no ass on her whatsoever she
suffered from no acid all right yeah
that's a talk
you don't just say
you don't say she suffered from no ass
at all
that's how you said it to me no no
you said no ass at all i said nocitol is
no acetol it's the disease
that's what we call it the disease
stupid nasty yeah
i heard myself
she got nasty
you